an explosive Exchange in the double
murder trial of disbarred South Carolina
attorney Alex murdaugh on his second day
on the stand prosecutors grilled Murda
over his timeline on the night of the
murders of his wife Maggie and their
youngest son Paul while Murdoch admitted
he lied to authorities he denied the
murders and pointed the blame elsewhere
Nikki Batiste was in the courtroom
in court Friday Alec Murdoch insisted
someone else was responsible for killing
his wife and son on June 7 2021. the
person or people who did what I saw
on June the 7th
they hated
Paul murdick what I'm telling you but
prosecutor Creighton Waters and CIS
Murdoch is the Killer and grilled him
for nearly six hours about his repeated
lying and you've been able to lie
quickly and easily and convincingly if
you think it'll save your skin for well
over a decade
investigators he never went to the dog
kennels the night his wife and son were
murdered the prosecutors say this cell
phone video places him there you were at
the murder scene
with the victims just minutes before
they died
I did not tell them that I went to the
kennel showing cell phone records Waters
points out Murdoch's cell phone which
was recording his steps became very
active 13 minutes after prosecutors say
his wife and Son's phones locked for the
final time what were you so busy doing
that's going to the bathroom no I don't
I don't think that I have to get on a
treadmill in the bathroom I didn't get
on the treadmill
no sir I did not do jumping jacks during
that time murdaugh also made several
phone calls something the prosecution
says was intentional you are up at 902
finally having your phone in your hand
moving around and making all these phone
calls to manufacture an alibi is that
not true absolutely incorrect the
defense says they hope to rest their
case by Tuesday which means the jury
would begin deliberations next week the
courtroom got so rowdy yesterday the
judge for the first time used his gavel
for CBS Saturday morning Nikki Batiste
Walterboro South Carolina